so dr simone gold who is perhaps most  famous for participating in the january  6th riots  tells mike lindell that she's forming  the legal eagle dream team to  end all lockdowns and the emergency use  authorizations  and the legal eagle dream team consists  of warrior attorneys who plan to bring  lawsuits really across the country  thanks to patriot takes for the heads up  on this one now first of all regarding  her forming the legal eagle dream team  uh rude and second of all this is not  going to work  there's a long line of cases that  basically allow  states and the federal government to  engage in lockdowns related to  pandemics it goes back hundreds of years  the founding of our country we've  covered this a lot on this channel  but efforts to claim that these laws are  illegal  they rarely work and i don't think this  effort is going to  work either now whether i should sue for  trademark infringement well that's  another matter entirely so i might see  her  in court